so 803 legend
who else can you kind of give us a
breakdown of like the hip-hop scene in
in south carolina specifically because i
feel like
like you were saying earlier a little
bit like it's almost harder to
like get support from your own people
until you start popping
and everybody want to come and jump on
see not like people fought with me
in carolina like no offense out but at
first it was like
i used to feel like i was it was me
against everybody but you know
because like it was like how i came
in in this [ __ ] like especially at home
but how it came out it was so
like unreal's like ain't no way he doing
it like that other than
like if you like in my immediate circle
then you notice
but other than that it's like man the
way he doing like that like
so it's hard for them to try to support
it or want to support it but
and then you gotta think we're coming
from like that [ __ ] is
it's a little country time so it's like
ain't nobody major
ain't nobody major came from out of
there like
the closest one we had was like little
roo yeah
[ __ ] like that little rule and that's
about it and i forgot about little real
yeah you know what i'm saying he never
really got to that that level like this
the biggest like the carolinas they ever
been like
period like south and north like that's
the biggest it hasn't been because
like when arnold even with like honor
did what he did but even with the artist
like me and baby got a
a a relationship where it's like we kind
of bridge the gap to
north and south carolina how long have
you guys had uh that like
because obviously baby independently
been running [ __ ] for a long time
you know and then but like how long did
you like like did you guys have a
rapport like
prior to you signing for sure yeah yeah
i knew baby like five years ago
right probably like five years ago like
we went to the studio together
it was just him by himself and me and my
brother put up we did like four five
songs that night
i been to baby and then like he used to
see me coming out there in the clubs
running around throwing money
doing stuff he'll do the same thing and
you know like
that's why he showed me the type of love
he showed me because he know like what
i'm talking about
like that boy really doing it like he
really comforting so that's why he
always showed me love anytime i
anytime i need him i can call him i just
called and asked him about some
some [ __ ] the other day he pick up every
time yeah that's big man